for you
um talk about like
you are listen 12 children yes 12 kids
um obviously your friends and Counting
some may say
nah I think I'm I'm good with my dirty
desert right now let me ask you
something
do you ever regret not getting Kim
Kardashian pregnant
how you try to go viral I'm just asking
I'm just asking because I look back at
your history and I'm like man if there
was ever anyone that you could have put
one up a bun in the oven it could have
been the billionaire uh you know what
I'm gonna leave that one alone
I'm tired of going viral every week they
already got mad at me about what I said
about Taylor Swift oh you didn't say you
Christina Milian so I know that's now he
says he's gonna get Kim Kardashian he
regrets because how would work how old
was Kim when you dated her uh we were
both like in our mid-20s was this post
love don't cost a thing or preach just
right after love don't gossip such a
classic [__] yeah just like a great
movie nah man it's fun we're back I mean
I stepped away from from uh I kind of
make like one movie a year that I own
and control but I think I'm gonna dive
back into movies in a little bit like
probably in the next five years and and
kind of get back to that space of like
making classic content for our community
have you thought about like their like
the lack of good comedies anything it's
crazy like done I think cancel culture
yeah yeah or just over sensitizing just
we lost all our our R-rated comedies
that made it like good comedy yeah this
trip was great yeah there's like 10
since some hangover yeah girls trip and
bridesmaids are the only two that yeah
yeah and those are I don't I don't well
those I guess those were those R-rated
guys yeah but like it's been 12 years
since we've gotten like a classic
hardcore comedy yeah no yeah I'm even in
the sense of like you said too just
stuff that even that you know you can
sit around and watch with the family too
like we don't have none of those like
family film we don't have yeah like
we're our forest gumps where you know
like where's the stuff like that
everything's like Marvel or yeah like
Billy Madison or the water boy like that
[__] used I remember Waterboy opened the
80 million dollars this first week you
know I mean like yeah no it's kind of
crazy because I always think like I'm
like someone Rich enough hello uh needs
to come along and just be like [__] it
you gotta focus on it though that's the
thing that to make a good movie you
gotta focus on that [__] like when it
takes the money uh but then it also you
gotta make sure your marketing is
together on the post and even like you
can't make a good movie without having a
great script so it's like it's stuff
like that that you just it it it's like
I've done independent films really well
too but then because you can make the
greatest independent film in the world
but if they don't reach the amount of
people then nobody ever really really
know except for the festivals that gave
you you know your little Laurels and
crests so if you to do a great classic
film you got to check the boxes from
development all the way to it's actually
in the theaters so it take it takes it
takes trust me people ask me all the
time and you should do more movies it's
like that's the most uh time consuming
[__] out there I bet it's to make a good
movie a good movie you could put you
could put some Hood classic Tubi [__]
out yeah shout out to me I [__] with
them heavy but like he's running it up
yeah but but if you if you want to make
some classic [__] if you want to make
Menace to Society boys in the hood uh
Drumline love don't cost a thing I mean
like I think you know probably for the
culture they did it the right way uh I
love it with Mike B is doing from you
know I feel like Cree to go down
Classics I feel like black panther go
down as Classics but anything else for
the culture ain't resonated except for
like those those Jordans I mean
obviously Jordan peels putting out some
crazy yeah but would you horror movie
yeah would that is that are we are we
gonna be talking about though I'm just a
question like I think I think get out
absolutely get out for sure get out I'm
not sure us or uh what's the last one
the other one [__] it just came out yeah
see that I mean yeah yeah like but no
offense but I'm like because you only
can and what time will tell as well you
know what I mean like like people people
didn't really start [__] with Love
Don't Cost a Thing heavy until back then
it was out on home video you know I mean
they did decent in the in the theaters
but then once it was constantly playing
that your auntie and your mama's house
all the time then it became a classic so
you know maybe these films that we're
talking about today but I'm saying the
ones that feel like you know what we
talk about we talking about Love Jones
we talk about do the right thing we'll
talk about the wood boys in the hood
there's none of that [__] yeah yeah our
people try but they come short every
time I've come short you know I'm like
damn you know why because the studio
didn't like I made a film called that
everybody is a hood classic like school
dance but everybody was talking is that
the one James is in James Jefferson yeah
yeah but everybody was talking like when
we was making it they was like oh this
is like the next Friday because
Davidson's in it yeah Pete Davidson
Tiffany haddish Kat Williams George
Lopez Mike Epps Kevin Hart little Duvall
like Brunell we had everybody in this
[__] and it's hilarious if you
watch it but because Lionsgate didn't
Market it correctly and they did they
did they didn't really know what they
had they just threw that [__] out there
so it's like you got it when I say from
the script to the time like it's [__]
in the theaters and like the marketing
all that everything got to be pristine
would you ever try to develop like a
scripted like drama or comedy or
something like we got some [__] we got
some [__] coming like I gotta I got a
pretty uh like I said I got deals at all
of these different because instead of
like I do feel like we we don't get it
in movies anymore but we do get it in
shows yeah we do it and that's so false
fire there's some great comedy shows
yeah so I got uh we've been developing
for a while and I just you know I I like
making more moves and less announcements
but I can I can tell you about the [__]
that we've been cooking up and spending
money on is uh uh me E40 and Too Short
uh got the yay area project is that the
one Simba's in uh no no not that one
that one's fire like that was playing
too short and yeah yeah I heard about no
I'm talking about this is like a series
that the three of us are producing
that's gonna be like the same way that
you see the bmfs the the powers the the
wives are you just trying to put it
together and then shop ah some things I
can't talk about right now but I heard
50 cents leaving Stars they could use
you now hey that's good business over
there but I mean like I do have a few
deals set up around town that allow me
to do scripted things so we excited
about it